8h ce matin environ 200 élèves du lycée
pasteur sont bloqués devant les portes
de l'établissement
une partie des lycéens a décidé de faire
front il dénonce des conditions
inadaptées à la situation sanitaire
alors que jakobi on est 35 35 36 dans
des salles et après on nous dit oui on
ne voyait pas trop vos amis tout ça a
été de 136 élèves au lycée pasteur on a
pas d'espacés couverts adaptés pour
manger si ces parcelles où on a
plus de 200 élèves qui sont sans masque
agglutinés les uns les autres
pareil dans la queue pour y aller c'est
la même chose dans les escaliers 9
heures une autre grille est ouverte et
la plupart des élèves parviennent
finalement à entrer dans la cour une
cinquantaine de contestataires persiste
mais tous ne sont pas d'accord sur la
façon de protester ici là on peut voir
des élèves qui sont avec leurs enceintes
qui dansent et je trouve que c'est pas
qu'on va dire là on perd beaucoup en
crédibilité
30 ou 35 élèves par classe malgré le
confinement
du côté de l'inspection académique on
assure que les normes sanitaires sont
bien respectées je crois qu'il faut
nuancer l'analyse de ces quelques
lycéens car le protocole sanitaire cathy
mise en place a été bien évidemment
validé par l'ensemble des scientifiques
les corps médical et puis par le pouvoir
politique
il est appliqué scrupuleusement dans
toutes les écoles collèges et lycées et
dès lors que ce protocole est appliquée
ça signifie que la sécurité sanitaire
des élèves est assurée au lycée pasteur
la situation est progressivement revenue
au calme
les cours devraient se tenir normalement
aujourd'hui